The China Huarong story is
about stress and turmoil at
what is one of China's largest
managers of distressed debt.
In one of the country's most high-profile
corruption cases,
the former chairman of state-owned
China Huarong Asset Management
has been sentenced to death.
Lai Xiaomin was convicted
of receiving more than
$270 million over a decade.
The rare and tough sentence...
That was considered a
particularly harsh punishment
for corruption.
In part the swift
sentencing was taken to be
the latest sign of the
Chinese Communist Party
cracking down on corruption,
particularly within the financial system
and within the political system.
We do have breaking news
coming from Huarong,
this troubled asset manager
here. Just seeing reports
of a looming restructuring of
course playing out on this,
and the bond rout there is deepening.
Investors concerned about
the finances of state-owned
bad-debt manager China Huarong,
and its silence isn't helping.
I'm standing outside...
China Huarong's bond prices
have been incredibly volatile
over the last two months.
It's of huge concern
because this could test
China's debt-ridden financial sectors
and the technocrats that run it
as well as all of the foreign banks
and the investors who have been
caught in between the drama.
My name is Rebecca Choong Wilkins.
I'm a reporter and
editor for Bloomberg News
China credit team.
China Huarong is one of China's largest
distressed-debt managers.
It's a so-called bad bank.
It has long been considered
of systemic importance,
partly because its largest shareholder
is the Ministry of Finance.
It was created in 1999 along
with three other asset managers
to try and deal with some of the bad debt
in China's economy.
So those were things like bonds or loans
that companies had defaulted on.
And they're considered
essential to the running
of China's $54 trillion financial market.
So-called bad banks help carry that risk
on their own balance sheet and help curb
all of that bad debt and
remove it essentially
away from the rest of
the financial system.
And that allows China's
other financial institutions
and its other banks to continue
with different kinds of banking services
that essentially help China's
economy to continue growing.
Lai Xiaomin ran China
Huarong from 2012 until 2018.
He was also sometimes
known as the God of Wealth,
had a background in some of China's
top financial institutions.
He had posts in the People's Bank of China
as well as China's Banking and Insurance
Regulatory Commission.
Under Lai Xiaomin's
leadership at China Huarong,
he expanded from the
firm's original mandate
dealing with bad debts into things like
securities trading and trusts.
He also turned to the public debt markets
to try and fund some of that expansion.
So under Lai Xiaomin, we
also saw a massive expansion
of the firms' bonds, outstanding bonds.
And those types of debts
were sold to both mainland
onshore investors as well
as global investors overseas
in the form of dollar
bonds as well as yuan-
and Hong Kong dollar-denominated bonds.
Lai Xiaomin was sometimes
criticized for just caring about
short-term profits and trying
to go way beyond the brief
of what traditionally a
bad bank like China Huarong
would be dealing with.
He was actually charged with bribery
and taking illicit payments.
In the course of the trial,
it came to light that
Lai Xiaomin had over the
years collected a spate
of luxury cars, of luxurious apartments
and expensive watches.
He had an apartment that he
had renamed "the supermarket"
that was later found to have cabinets
that were full of cash.
And a lot of this came to
light during the trial,
some of which was televised
and became quite a public spectacle.
He was executed earlier this year.
The former board chairman
of one of China's
biggest asset-management
companies, Lai Xiaomin
was executed on Friday, authorities said.
It was found...
So Wang Zhanfeng was appointed afterwards
to take over the running of China Huarong
and essentially to try and
get it back onto a safe
and steady footing.
That included things like
shaping up its financial health
and pulling back from
some of the riskier areas
that Lai Xiaomin has expanded
into under his leadership.
He was seen to be
certainly not as flamboyant
as his predecessor,
but also brought in specifically
to try and introduce
a more serious and
professional management style
at China Huarong too.
Concerns first flared at the
company at the end of March
when the firm failed to release
its 2020 annual reports.
Fundamentally, what it
means is that investors
and we don't have a very
clear insight into precisely
how that cleanup has actually
gone over the last year.
So investors suddenly
started to worry that
there could be some issues
with its financial health.
Now that was then exacerbated
by several media reports
that there could be a potential
financial restructuring
at China Huarong.
Well, obviously this has
been a saga now. Last week
in a speculation about a
possible debt restructuring
sent its overseas bonds
down to record lows.
Got another ratings downgrade for Huarong.
You've got to wonder
whether this is a little bit
of a delayed reaction.
Well, as we've seen it
has been a rocky April for
Huarong bond investors.
And we have seen those notes
continue to hit fresh lows
and in the wake of this
New York Times report...
China Huarong's bond prices
have been incredibly volatile
over the last two months.
In fact, they've been far and
away the most volatile trading
that we've seen in the
offshore bond market.
And they've actually weighed
on the broader bond market
as well.
China Huarong is one
of the bigger borrowers
among Chinese firms.
At the moment it has
about $40 billion worth
of outstanding bonds in the
onshore and offshore market.
About $4 billion of
that needs to be repaid
or refinanced this year.
When China Huarong first started selling
a lot of offshore debt,
it was considered by investors
to be a really safe bet.
It was considered a quasi-sovereign.
It had an investment-grade quality rating
and the debt itself was really popular
among many institutional investors
and many international investors.
Firms like BlackRock,
Allianz and Goldman Sachs
were all once buyers of the notes.
Now the offshore investors
are in a little bit
of a tricky situation.
One reason why investors
have become so worried
and so panicked about China
Huarong is the relative silence
since they said they would be
delaying their 2020 results.
We've really only seen the
company and regulators come out
once or twice with public
comments to try and ease concerns.
Regulators, for example,
have said that China Huarong
has ample liquidity
and that its operations
are running normally.
Similarly, we've seen some
comments from the company itself
also trying to reassure investors
that its liquidity is good
and that its operations
are running normally.
However, there generally
has been a kind of
lack of information around
precisely what's going to happen
at the company.
What we do know is that
senior management has become
much more accustomed to
meeting with regulators
and authorities and having
last-minute meetings.
And we also know that the
company is now providing
a weekly update on how its
liquidity conditions are going
and whether or not its
operations are running normally.
In the short term, China
Huarong is expected
to meet its debt repayments.
And that's partly because
Huarong has been said to come
to this agreement where state
banks will support meeting
its debt obligations that
come due through August.
On the other hand, however,
the longer-term concerns
about the fate of China Huarong persist.
Ultimately investors now are
waiting to see whether or not
Beijing and authorities
step in to provide a kind of
guarantee or a kind of
bailout to China Huarong.
I think the assumption generally is that
authorities do not want to
see a failure at Huarong,
which roils the broader market.
If we were to see fundamental
and painful restructuring
of China Huarong,
or if we were allowed to see
any kind of payment failure
at a firm like Huarong,
which is considered to be
of systemic importance,
which was backed by
central government institutions,
then that really would
change the way that investors
look at this market.